your faith and President Trump well as I  say I've been concerned that some of the  things he's decided I think his last  choice for my security advisor was very  ill-advised I think John Bolton has been  the worst mistake he's made he's  advocated going to war preemptively  against North Korea against Iraq against  Iran even and so I think that that is  particularly ill-advised because that  Security Advisor I know from experience  is the most listened to advice that a  president guess but I still think that  our country can overcome in the  president's new national security  adviser has advocated a preemptive  strike in North Korea what would that do  that would be a total disaster